[Music]  this is the fall to dip your toe in the  water and then to go deep  [Music]  start with a fine gauge turtleneck that  means a lighter weight that you can wear  under a suit can also ran under jean  jacket the turn alike is extremely  elegant if you look back through history  you'll see pictures of Sean Connery in  his early days as James Bond you'll see  James Dean wearing a turtleneck you'll  see Paul Newman wearing a turtleneck it  is an iconic style piece you wear it in  a stylish way the turtleneck is really a  young modern elegant look start with  something neutral and I bet you'll get  bucked I bet you'll be buying more  turtlenecks before  is over  [Music]